the Ray Rice story is obviously the big
story in the sports world and in
domestic news right now
so of course Ray Rice from the Baltimore
Ravens he has now been released by the
Ravens as of two days ago he punched his
fiancee in an elevator so let's just
watch the video quick I know you guys
have seen it but we're going to throw to
that and then we'll break it down
you
okay I mean I've now seen that thing
probably 20 times and it's awful each
time I mean just her lifeless body when
he drags her out of the elevator
her name is janae Palmer they actually
got married they are married right now
and she released the statement on
Instagram explaining the situation so
let's take a look that she said no one
knows the pain that the media and
unwanted opinions from the public has
caused my family to make us relive a
moment in our lives that we regret every
day as a horrible thing to take
something away from the man I love that
he has worked his ass off for all his
life just to gain ratings is horrific
this is our life what you don't all get
if your intentions were to hurt us
embarrass us make us feel alone take all
happiness away you've succeeded on so
many levels ok so we still got more that
I want to get to but let's just start
with that part so yes the Ravens have
suspended him now apparently the NFL did
know of the tape for months they
apparently didn't see it until two days
ago that's what Roger Goodell the NFL
Commissioner saying and that's when they
then decided to suspend him so we're not
getting into all the minutia of the NFL
and all that's at lisps we have two
ladies on the panel let's just talk
about that part of it I sort of look I
sympathize with her of course that
something awful happened to her and it's
they're up to them in their private
lives if they want to get married and if
they're in love and if he's truly if
she's truly forgiven him and all that
what do you make of her her statement I
mean she said several things apologizing
for even for her part in it like she
takes responsibility for it and I feel
terrible for her and the fact that she
married him a month after this happened
is crazy to me and I know that the NFL
he said they didn't see the tape until
two days that's what they're claiming
but you really need to see someone
getting knocked out to know that it's
not an okay thing to do I mean cuz
initially they only tried to suspend him
for what two games right well initially
they saw the tape this is what initially
they claimed they saw the tape of her
from the outside of the elevator so they
saw essentially her life with potty just
being dumped there and was like oh maybe
she was drunk maybe she fell we don't
know the goings on and so they swept it
under the
they thought they could get away with it
and I think that so just to clarify real
quick so they're saying that they didn't
see the punch okay yeah that's what
they're yeah they're saying that they
didn't see the actual goings-on there
until two days ago yeah um so that's why
initially they suspended him for two
games only now the thing is here like
there's a much bigger discussion that
needs to be had and it's unfortunate
that she's coming back in and feeling
the need to apologize first of all but
also feel the need to just personalize
this I mean I understand this is very
personal to her and and I understand
this issue is going on between the two
of them but the thing that she needs to
understand here and that people need to
understand is being that this is on such
a large scale of things like this is a
discussion it needs to be had regarding
domestic violence and you know if you're
going to you know commit this act have
it be in a public place and have it be
videotaped and you're in a public forum
in general be expect your ask to be
handed to you right so is that part of
the craziness now just the general
24-hour news cycle and all that that I
look I'm not privy to their private
relationship so they may well be in love
and trying to build a life together and
all that I could see you're not even
onboard that like you think I really see
so I find it hard to call something love
that's abusive like that yeah so I mean
I understand that that victims tend to
sympathize with their abuser a lot of
the times and I think that's what we're
seeing you know happen right now and
like you said it's part of a bigger
discussion on domestic abuse that we
need to have and since it's not just
their private life he's a very public
figure it's a role model for everyone
yeah so if you let someone this you know
well-known get away with it you're
sending a message to everyone out there
that this is okay to happen you're also
the thing is you're also sending a
message here that just don't get caught
almost because the thing is 21 out of 32
NFL teams have members on their team
that have been convicted or committed
domestic abuse or sexual abuse there's
three cases pending right now you know
between the 49ers player there's a
couple other ones and it's just like
okay this person just happened to get
caught doing it so it I mean I don't
know I think at the same token of the
NFL taking such drastic action and
suspending him the Baltimore Ravens
still
stood up and one of their first
statements that they said was about
janae apologizing and her for her role
in it so it's like even though they
suspended him they're still taking her
in as an accomplice to the situation
which I think is well it seems very
clear to me that unless there's a video
that this the league knows that there
are tons of criminals and it's not just
the league that all sports they know
that there's all awful stuff going on
there's people doing drugs and beating
women and all kinds of harm they could
literally start another league just for
the criminals now that might be it was
like a battle royale of football you
know and I think but I think the fact
that we've suspended players and I say
we because I'm a chairman on the board
of the NFL um for for smoking weed for a
year and then you get a two-game
suspension for doing god-knows-what and
an elevator until you see what really
unfolded I think is completely asinine
yeah well to that point so keith
olbermann who has a show on ESPN now he
is pissed that basically everybody
involved in the situation from top to
bottom so let's take a look each body
each leading individual involved came to
a judicial conclusion about what had
happened to janay Palmer and what should
happen to Ray Rice and each through
deception or incompetence mislead the
public damage the efforts of every man
and every woman in this country seeking
to merely slow down the murderous
epidemic of domestic violence and made a
mockery of the process by which those
who batter those they claim to love are
to be brought to justice and not one of
them not Commissioner Goodell not NFL
senior vice president Adolfo Burch not
NFL chief counsel Jeff pash not
Baltimore team president Richard cast
not Baltimore general manager Ozzie
Newsome not assistant prosecutor Diane
ruh Burton of Atlantic County New Jersey
not prosecutor Jim McLain not Superior
Court Judge Michael doe no not Ray Rice
himself no matter what actions were
taken today against Rice nor what might
be taken in the future none of them have
any remaining credibility and each must
leave or be expelled from their current
positions okay well yeah yeah roll call
you [ __ ] that yeah he i mean clearly the
guy is not mincing any words i think he
makes some really good points this order
reminded me actually
of the whole Penn State sex abuse thing
where it was systemic and everyone sort
of knew and who do you fire and how'd
you know do you blame the coach and the
president and the vice president and all
that for watching that in slow motion
like this is why exactly doing an ESPN
like football slow-mo replay of that
like sock out I just don't understand
like I saw it I don't need to see it
like in slow motion like a hundred times
I get it it's really nothing it's sort
of like the Isis beheading things it's
like we watch them and like it's gross
but you sort of have to see it things a
lot of people try to sweep under the rug
and pretend doesn't happen whenever you
see it right there in front of your face
it's too hard to ignore
yeah do you agree with him I mean I know
obviously we're not NFL owners and and
regardless of your feelings on sports in
general but is this a type of thing
where the NFL just has to clean house
now like they really have to send a
statement like you guys knew what was
going on whether you saw the video two
days ago or even if it comes out that
they saw it a month ago just get rid of
some of these people absolutely I think
these people need to be you know taught
that this is not okay you can't support
it like I said before you know their
public figures so what they do reflects
on society and people look to them as an
example so if you don't take care of it
when it happens it's going to perpetuate
itself I mean it's it's such a large
discussion because you can look into
like well why aren't music executives
fired for not you know tarnishing Chris
Brown's contract or why aren't like
politician I mean what there's so many
different sectors of of business and
politics and sports that we would all it
would all just shut down everybody fired
everyone tired yeah fire so glad you
brought that up cuz I do think that's a
really interesting point because I was
noticing how everybody I get all my
information from Twitter these days
everyone on Twitter is clamoring for him
to be fired then he did get fired okay
or let go whatever you want to call it
and everybody was happy but it was kind
of making me think look if if this was
an accountant I get your point about the
public figure part of this but if you
were an accountant and you beat your
wife and there was video of it um you
would still be allowed to be an
accountant once the legal proceedings
took you know were resolved or whatever
um so is there something like should we
should we be holding sports people to
higher standards than regular citizen
you know I mean I think it's just the
public eye if you're in the public eye
you're and you know fan dollars and
people's money is going to your salaries
and you don't have the personal power to
hire them like I wouldn't hire an
accountant that I knew it was an abuser
you know what I mean and I wouldn't want
to go to a game where I like all the
other players but this douchebag is
beating his wife you're presenting the
team a whole you know it's a larger
picture and they might not want him to
be representative of them yeah so are
you guys down with the idea that he'll
be banned for life I mean that's what
some people are saying do you think it's
like a privilege for him to be able to
play again I mean what's up with homeboy
who like was in the dog fighting and
then now he's back with Michael Vick and
now he's back with a vengeance and
people totally forgot it all so who
knows he could be back you know it could
be a passing thing yeah
all right well this story is probably
not going away so we will see what
happens